you know uh whenever I hear people
confused about why all schools cell
animation has been preserved so poorly
over the years I'm just reminded that
folks don't seem to realize how much of
a pain it is to store the film like even
with huge anime like Dragon Ball people
seem perplexed as to why they don't
simply keep pristine copies of the
original Masters for future releases to
scan and remaster but like film is Big
Man it takes up space for reference here
is the film reel for Oppenheimer now
that movie is filmed on 70 millimeter
film which takes up a lot more space
than the smaller film reels anime were
shot on but remember Oppenheimer is only
three hours long how much of a pain and
expense do you think storing nearly 200
hours of footage for Dragon Ball alone
would take up not to mention the ton of
other shows they produce film is big
guys but that's also what makes it great
the more of the story I don't know go
see Oppenheimer in 70 millimeter IMAX I
guess I don't know